hello and sorry I'm getting this review
up a little late I was out fighting
vampire hookers trying to avert the
apocalypse but apocalypse averted now
let's get on to this review the gray are
so the gray stars Liam Neeson and he
works for this Alaskan oil refinery and
so he's on a plane ride with a bunch of
these Alaskan roughneck guys a lot of
them kind of don't have their own handle
on life you know and so their plane
crashes in the middle of the Alaskan
nowhere and now they're in a
life-and-death situation the weather
will probably kill you and if it doesn't
the wolves will yeah wolves keep coming
in and out and trying to kill them and
yes I've heard enough hipsters out there
be like actually wolves don't attack
people they just shut up they kind of
explain it in this movie as to why
they're coming after them plus I saw the
ghost in the darkness and even though
that had to do with lions instead of
wolves still changed my perception on
this anyway back to the movie which
I was like yes I love these survival
kind of movies but survival movies can
be one of two ways awesome or not
remotely likable fact quite stupid
luckily this one is actually awesome
first of all in the lead you got Liam
Neeson initially you're like okay if
everyone else in this movie sucks Liam
Neeson's enough to carry this and he's
mr. wolf know-it-all you know he knows
how they think he knows why they're
attacking them so he's like okay if we
do this we're gonna make it out of here
and after that intensity and wolves and
blood and people getting picked off
which was cool to see but this movie is
really well directed there are a couple
scenes where you're like that's creepy
in a degree that I wouldn't have thought
to make it like I'll pick a scene from
the trailer because I don't want to ruin
anything for you Liam Neeson's holding
this fiery stick into the darkness and
you see this wolves eyes they're just
glowing looking at him and then a bunch
of other wolves eyes and you're like ah
that's a bit too much for wee fleshy
little humans to take on and that's
exciting enough but the movie was really
good on character the ultimate theme of
this movies you find out what makes you
tick as a human being when you're put in
the middle of nowhere were the rules of
human civilization no longer apply and
there are some intense moments I got to
escape the danger and you know they're
all being witty and they're like okay
physically we're not going to go up
against these wolves and live so we got
to use our brains it's good to see that
you know those people that are like
don't worry I'm all like I watched
MacGyver there's even a douchebag in
this movie you know that guy you know
the guy in the movie that you're like I
don't like him now but I might just like
him later on you do like him later on I
like it when a movie can pull that off
well this is like the darker older
brother of 127 hours
I say that because it's more like hell
for me I hate the cold this is Alaska it
is cold and upon all this the fact
remains that in a movie like this it's
all about survival they're going to be
two kinds of people in the world people
who love the ending and people who hate
the ending I myself really liked the
ending it looks like I was going to like
it then it looks like I wasn't going to
like it and then I ended up liking it
that's my cryptic version of the ending
in the end this is my favorite movie of
2012 that might not be saying too much
because we're not even in February yet
we're in January which is really slim
pickins for good movies but I'm just
saying there might not be a movie for
quite some time that these Thrones this
movie has my favorite movie of 2012 the
grey is awesome tacular loved it loved
the characters love the intensity loved
the ending loved the movie why is it
called the grey you asked because in
this PC world you can't call it the
white and not piss people off you can't
call it the black and not piss people
off call it the grey no one gets mad
mium Hulk say you racist is right so I
forgot about grey Hulk sorry buddy so
your favorite survival in the middle of
nowhere movie what is it comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more